u.s president donald trump is on the
verge of becoming the first leader of
the united states to be impeached
twice the house of representatives is
moving forward with a vote to impeach
trump
in a few hours time a number of key
republicans now say they also
back the move trump will face a single
charge of incitement of insurrection
over the storming of the capital
building by his supporters last week
trump denies he encouraged the violence
president trump has been subject to
massive criticism of late
but he can still draw loyal supporters
banned from major social media outlets
trump seized the opportunity on tuesday
to reconnect with his base he headed to
texas to talk about one of his favorite
topics
the border wall with mexico but before
that
he remarked about efforts to remove him
from
office the impeachment hoax is a
continuation of the greatest and most
vicious witch hunt
in the history of our country and is
causing tremendous anger and division
and pain
far greater than most people will ever
understand
which is very dangerous for the usa
especially
at this very tender time his comments
came
as debate continued in the house of
representatives
democrats are stepping up their efforts
to remove the president from office
democrats accused trump of having
incited the capital riots
and say failing to hold him to account
would be a dangerous precedent
all of us should do some soul searching
about five dead americans
a capital police officer who's dead
dozens of people wounded
lots of our capitol hill cops in the
hospitals
and a country on edge and an inflamed
right wing
which thinks that we are on the verge of
a civil war
the assault on the capitol has eroded
support for trump and congress
several republican lawmakers say they're
willing to back
impeachment efforts they now include
five members of the house of
representatives notably
liz cheney the number three republican
in the chamber
she's released a statement saying the
storming of the capital was trump's
doing
and that he did nothing to stop the
violence
she said there has never been a greater
betrayal by a president
of the united states of his office and
his oath to the constitution
cheney's move lays bare a split among
republicans
over trump and the future of their party
i'm joined now by dw reporter peter
rollerdale peter
impeachment is moving forward at a swift
pace in the house of representatives
what's the latest on the efforts to
remove trump from office
well today really is set to be a
historic day donald trump all for sure
to become
the first president in u.s history to be
impeached twice
it is really notable that over a dozen
republicans have indicated that they'll
back that effort
just over a year ago the first time
donald trump was impeached
exactly zero house republicans voted to
impeach
but the insurrection on january 6 really
does appear to have been the last role
for many in his party high-ranking
republican
member uh liz cheney released a strongly
worded statement saying that
there's never been a greater betrayal by
a president of the united states
of his office it's owed to the
constitution it really does signal a
strong break
with trump who's fighting himself
increasingly isolated athletes the white
house
and that many republicans really see the
party at a crossroads you know according
reports
senate majority-led uh senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
has even indicated that uh he believes
impeaching
trump is not just the easiest way to get
rid of the president but also get rid of
trumpism from the republican party
whether that translates into trump
actually being removed from office is a
different question
you would still need a two-thirds
majority uh in the senate to do that
and that's all but guaranteed yeah he's
a man under siege what's the president
himself been saying about all of this
he's been
digging his heels in somewhat hasn't he
right donald trump never was one to
admit mistakes and
his first public appearance since the uh
violence that was on capitol hill last
wednesday
really was no different on tuesday he
went down to texas
and trump continued to deny any
culpability uh
in the violent riot that left you know a
lot of people dead um
and threaten the lives really of not
just members of congress but of his own
vice president
trump insisted that his remarks to his
supporters in washington
which many took to be an encouragement
to essentially storm the capital but
those remarks were quote
totally appropriate trump also warned
that his impeachment
could lead to more violence and that
statement has worried a lot of people
because they know that trump supporters
are hanging on just every word
and could read this as a tacit
encouragement
to even more unrest peter stay with us
we'll come back to you
in a moment but first let's take a look
at this report on preparations
and the increased security measures in
washington ahead of next week's
inauguration
time to tighten the screws washington is
boarding up
in anticipation of the presidential
inauguration
victor and his colleagues have their
hands full
with work they have never seen the city
like this
everybody is afraid because we don't
know nothing right now
so we try to do like best like
protection or
big safety for the people instead of
festive celebrations
businesses brace for damages
and at the capitol security has been
ramped up significantly
the atmosphere here at the capitol is
very different compared to last week
for one an over two meter high fence was
erected
and is patrolled by members of the
national guard
additional police is roaming the streets
all of which
to guarantee the safe inauguration of
president-elect joe biden
next week on the steps in front of the
capital
the big worry is that pro-time
supporters
will try to disrupt the ceremonies but
police
wants to be better prepared this time
the city is in a state of emergency
buses with national guard troops arrive
around the clock
up to 15 000 soldiers could be deployed
in the city
meanwhile the stage is set preparations
are on the go but a celebration
certainly feels different
you know i'm excited for joe biden to
assume the presidency but at the same
time
as i continue to read reports about the
potential insurrection here again
potential insurrection
across all 50 us capitals it concerns me
to say the least
i think now that we saw that the capital
was stormed i think
there's a high chance that we'll see
more people who think that that means
that they can just behave like that
i feel safe now i mean this place looks
like an armed camp at the moment
are discouraging americans from coming
to dc on inauguration day
like many others victor will stay holed
up at home instead
i would prefer to stay in a house see
for the tv what's going on because i
don't want to go out
it will be a hard task for biden to
bring the barricades between americans
down again
so still with us here in berlin as our
reporter peter rollerdale peter
lots of security on hand for the
inauguration which uh was not really the
case
last week and law enforcement in the u.s
is also warning of
major trouble looming
right we've seen a lot of activity on
social media by trump supporters
planning more violent protests in the
days ahead of the insurrection
one of the big dates there's january
17th and it really just
shows just how coordinated they are and
what we saw last wednesday uh
was far from just a spontaneous act of
rebellion
um america's senior military leaders the
military joint
uh chiefs have also come out releasing a
statement condemning
the intervention that we saw last week
in the capitol
and really reminded their service
members to
uh you know their obligations to support
and defend the constitution and that is
notable because usually
these high-ranking military leaders get
out of their way to do anything that
could be interpreted
as a political and this really come to
mind reports
that uh you know as i said several
violent rallies are being planned
ahead of the inauguration but also amid
reports
that the fbi actually knew that this was
going to happen an internal memo
suggesting
that they were aware of all these plans
um on january 6 before it happened so
a lot of pressure to avoid a repeat of
january 6.
peterborough ladau thanks so much
thank you the business world is moving
much more quickly
against the u.s president than the
political world the new york times
reports that germany's biggest lender
deutsche bank
says that it will no longer do business
with president trump or
his companies deutsche bank is the
biggest lender to the trump
organization which is being run at the
moment by the president's sons
deutsche bank's move follows last week's
assault on the capitol by a mob of trump
supporters
deutsche joins a growing list of
companies that have cut ties
to donald trump
all right for more now i'm joined here
by my colleague kate ferguson from dw
business kate it's good to see you we
um know that deutsche bank was the only
bank willing to lend donald trump money
no american lenders were willing to do
that how much of a blow is this going to
be then to donald trump
well brent this is really the moment
that all the elements that were propping
donald trump up are beginning to crumble
politically personally and now
financially as well so a large chunk of
the republican party no longer supports
him social media platforms have banned
him and now the money tops are being
turned off as well
when it comes to deutsche bank
specifically this has been an incredibly
important relationship as you mentioned
most mainstream lenders
stayed well away from donald trump
because of his reputation for not paying
back his loans
he currently owes deutsche bank about
million dollars those loans are due to
be repaid
in 2023 and 2024. now if you can't come
up with the cash deutsche can actually
seize his personal assets
and given how increasingly isolated
trump is looking that is not an
outlandish prospect amazing
there's a lot to this trump deutsche
bank relationship isn't there i mean i
know there are suspicions of a
connection between
deutsche russia and donald trump
well yeah this is a relationship that
has lasted longer than any of donald
trump's marriages has
and just to give you just to give you an
idea um
the woman who managed deutsche bank's
affairs at
um or managed donald trump's affairs
with deutsche rosemond vlabek
she was a vip guest at his inauguration
so that gives you some idea of just how
cozy the relationship has been
um the money that he borrowed he used to
buy luxury hotels
golf courses skyscrapers but that same
woman rosemary rabbit
she resigned very abruptly last month
from deutsche bank
what we know is that she was the subject
of an internal
investigation into a purchase of an
apartment
from a company that was partly owned by
none other than gerald kushner
trump's son-in-law so if it seems like
deutsche bank is now just jumping on the
bandwagon
because everyone else is actually they
have been trying to distance themselves
from trump for a while now because quite
frankly he is bad for their business
well other companies they are also
rushing to distance themselves
from donald trump aren't they yeah it's
really a domino effect and one of the
most interesting examples of this i
think is
stripe the payments company so it is no
longer processing donations to trump's
campaign website
and that potentially could be a huge
blow now the other
lender that was working with with trump
signature bank they have closed his
account
and they have also called for his
resignation and of course
many other companies like microsoft at t
and airbnb they're no longer donating to
republicans who are not accepting joe
biden's election victory so it certainly
does look like the
business empire is crumbling yeah in the
u.s in politics money talks
that's for sure kate ferguson as always
kate thank you thanks so much